[Music]
they should be [ __ ] put to death for
what they did
there you go there's a hot take that's
the other thing that's annoying it's
like not only should this stop it should
cease to exist yeah you're like well
that's a little trumpy he goes uh we we
hit a snag we really love you we think
you're a star but we're not taking white
guys
and I was just like what the [ __ ] you
gave people money
limited money because of the race that
they happen to be born into and you
denied it to others on the basis of race
have you ever thought of moving yes
[Laughter]
left-wing conspiracy to deny the
presidency to Donald Trump absolutely it
was absolutely right but I think it was
warranted you were saying you are
content
with a left-wing conspiracy to prevent
somebody being democratically re-elected
as president more commonly it's called
the forced organ harvesting
reality in China they basically looked
at all these Chinese officially
published Chinese studies in medical
journals and they found through looking
at protocols very carefully 71 instances
in the published literature where people
had been killed by heart extraction
I thought that you know this is
something that starts at the age of 18.
but no I mean they chopped the breasts
off of uh
13 and 14 year old girls even younger
sometimes is what's the one thing when
when bad not bad
[Music]
[Music]
hello oh no way bro
no [ __ ] way dog
that's not real
man what is look we do a formal intro
all right let's just get it over there
all right
that's how we normally start our
interviews let's get it over with right
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster oh come on dog you got to
do better than that I agree with you
thank you sorry man I'm not trying to
tell you what to do you know what you're
doing but you gotta try harder bro
all right
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constance and kissing
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People a brilliant guest today is
already taking the piss out of us it's
the amazing American comedian Theo Von
welcome to trigonometry you guys have we
call it autism
Mark normandy's looking around for it
welcome to trigonometry brother hey good
to be here I said before it looks like
the game of Clue this is so nice and the
chair is great I mean this is a sweet
pad we have so much now you know like we
used to be scared we used to have raids
in uh classrooms where they'd play this
noise and then you all got onto your
desk because the Russians might be
bombing when that's going on you're not
worried about pronouns you know you're
like [ __ ] we could be bombed right now
and now we have Shooters and we're still
like can you believe that he said [ __ ]
in 1978. we just it's just we got it
pretty good now we got Uber Eats yeah we
just sit at home and get food delivered
and shoved in our fat faces and so we're
like hmm I need something I need to like
get my blood pumping hey this guy uh is
in blackface in the 40s you know sorry
I'm rambling no the rambling is good
okay yeah no it's I I think there's
there's a lot to be said for that the
fact that you know people get upset by
jokes yeah like before the pandemic I
was doing you know digging six nights a
week on the London circuit doing all
these big clubs and I remember like I
started to get curious about all of this
stuff and I remember asking all the club
Owners in London going have complaints
gone up every single one of them said
yes by a huge amount that's interesting
you know what has happened that people
listen to a joke and suddenly go not
only do I not like it which is your
right it's your right not to laugh
absolutely it is but it's also their
right to go and demand that that person
not be booked again at a club or not
have or just not say that joke right
right yeah that's the other thing that's
annoying it's like not only should they
start but should cease to exist yeah
you're like well that's a little trumpy
that's a little uh fascisty or whatever
like you're this dictator hey get rid of
it it's it's offensive but like to who
and then then we do this thing where
I'll do like a black room and it kills
the jokes killed and I'll do a white
room and they're like that's offensive
to black people I'm like well tell the
uh 200 people the black people laughing
man that's exactly what I found like I
used to have a bunch of jokes about me
having dark skin and and people think
talking I'm from Pakistan and all of
that [ __ ] and he was always ethnic
minority rooms where that went down
really well yeah and it was always the
guilty white people
exactly every time so isn't that a
little [ __ ] up you're speaking for
them it's this weird soft racism hey
they can't handle that that's a little
over the line whatever and you're like
they've been through so much and you're
worried about this joke about not being
able to swim you know what are we doing
here yeah so there's a lot of uh a lot
of weird soft bigotry of like
we'll handle this they're brown yeah let
us do it and you're like well how come
that's not offensive yeah but then Megan
the joke was and I think the joke thing
to your point is just I think it's a
young generational thing I think younger
people maybe they're they're they grew
up with this online outrage and like we
got to stop this we got to stop that and
so then they see it in real life and
they weren't ready for it they're like
whoa I can't believe it we should do
something you know because everybody's
living on a pillow right now you know
and so when you go out into the real
world and hear a joke about [ __ ] up
[ __ ]
it's hot it's heavy it's like whoa I
didn't see that coming and you can't
pick what a comic says everything else
in life is Catered now Tinder it's like
oh that ugly fat tall gay whatever even
your meal I don't want uh gluten dairy
whatever but then you go to a comedy
show and it's all fresh and you're like
whoa I didn't I didn't pick this but and
you don't have control you don't have
control they like control these people
can play and they like control and we've
always had these people sure but it
definitely has upped but we've never
given them a megaphone before that's
right that too yeah and not only do we
they not have a megaphone but now we
listen yeah we cater to that one queef
who was upset about the wheelchair joke
and like I've seen stuff where they're
like no fat jokes and a guy's like I'm
400 pounds my whole Act is fat jokes and
they're like yeah but he's like so now
you're trying to be Progressive and a
good guy but you're telling me what I
can't say what makes me feel better how
I get over my pain this is how I relieve
you know I feel better with with the
jokes and they're like yeah it's no good
it's like
so you're like a dictator like I can't
do my own fat this is my Act yeah I
heard Mark Norman was just here I can
still feel his hey hey
what are we doing you're gay is that why
this is the tears all torn up because it
moves around what are we doing I love
Mark yeah Mark's great uh but one of the
reasons we wanted to have you on is
obviously this situation with you and a
potential agent manager
um where you were about to get signed
they they said they really liked you and
then they were like we can't work with
you because you're a white guy yeah and
they're going to use this clip because
it is about 100 degrees in here and I'm
sweating yeah so I'm picturing in a year
when we're in court they're going to cut
to this clip and go look at him he's
sweating through it he's probably lying
about all of it uh yes yes so what
happened so what happened I this has
been happening for about 10 years every
once in a while a casting director would
say Hey you know I want to submit you
for this job but we're not really doing
the white guy thing right now okay
that's interesting and it it happened
more and more frequently
I'd be booked on a podcast get a text
hey not the best time to have a white
guy on yeah sorry about that yeah thanks
guys yeah you guys weren't even famous
yet
[ __ ]
anyway back to the story back to the
lawsuit right for eight for ten years
you've noticed that every now and again
you apply for something you know and
they're like we're not doing the white
guy thing at the moment yep constantly
one of the biggest jobs I actually got I
won't mention it but uh it was a casting
director who I knew personally she was a
fan of mine
um and she they them those I don't wanna
got to be careful there too uh and she
wrote to me she said I probably
shouldn't submit white guys for this
but I have a feeling you're a perfect
fit so I'm gonna sneak you in and again
I mean to look at that then I start to
feel like well I I don't deserve it why
it the the job had nothing to do with
race or gender or anything and I booked
the job
and every day I went and I did feel a
little bit like am I stealing this from
somebody because of the way she
presented it
um so yeah it just happened more and
more
and then I had an agent bring me in big
agent in New York
he goes why aren't you on SNL every year
around two months before SNL people
would bring me and go why aren't you on
SNL why aren't you famous and I'm like
well if you know if you want to help me
out that'd be great you know I don't
have Lauren's WhatsApp
so
a few months later radio silence and I I
emailed I said what's what's going on no
auditions nothing and he wrote back
and I quote tough out there for white
dudes and then they they removed me from
the roster I got an email that said
you've been removed so I was I was done
are you tired of using bulky old wallets
giving you a bulge where you don't want
it to be my old wallet was massive so it
brought all the ladies to the yard which
was a huge distraction and got in the
way of my esteemed work on trigonometry
reg wallets have an incredible solution
for you this is mine Sleek stylish and
with an industrial look to her it can
fit 12 cards with cash on the back using
a clip like this one or a strap we've
got one for the whole team I've got one
Francis has one even our producer Anthem
has one but he's from Liverpool so he
flogged his on the black market the
great thing about Ridge is that they
give you a lifetime guarantee which
means if you want you can have only one
wallet for the rest of your life rich is
so confident in the quality of their
product they will give you 45 days to
test drive their wallet that means you
can get the wallet use it and if you
don't like it you can return it within
45 days because Ridge is such great guys
they're going to give you 10 off and
free worldwide shipping and returns to
take advantage of this incredible offer
go to ridge.com forward slash trigger
that's ridge.com forward slash trigger
and use our special code which is of
course trigger
so then I I just stopped pursuing agents
and managers for a while started making
my own stuff this agent um
that I am suing or manager rather
reached out and said we love you we want
to get you auditions for Curb Your
Enthusiasm all this stuff and
um
said great
a few months later they reach out said
we want to call we want to get you on
the phone so I'm sitting there like all
right here we go finally it's all it's
all happening
and he goes uh we we hit a snag we
really love you we think you're a star
but we're not taking white guys
and I was just like what the f you know
been at this for 15 years not that I
deserve anything you know if I went my
whole career without getting booked on
something but I at least had the
opportunity to audition I'd feel okay
about that but what's happening now is
they're removing certain races from even
having the opportunity to compete and
that's what a manager or an agent is
they get you the opportunity to compete
that you otherwise can't unless you have
you know a big YouTube show like you
guys uh so I'm sitting there and I
remembered my therapist uh I was dating
a quite mentally unstable woman at the
time and he said you need to start
recording conversations if anything
comes up because you don't want to be
accused of the million things you can be
accused of and so I hit record
I said can you say that one one more
time
you know you like me yeah you think I'm
a star yeah but you won't work with me
because I'm white and I was like can you
say it a little slower a little slower
and uh I said is that company policy and
he said uh yeah it is and so
you know I hung up and I was crushed you
know I want I want to sit here and
pretend like I I it didn't bother me but
I cried
you know it was like this the little kid
when their balloon is just you know
getting taken away into the sky it's
like I saw my career just
I tried everything you know I worked 12
hours a day seven days a week I do all
the shows I I've been making sketches
and I just thought without this
gatekeeper I'm not gonna make it and so
um I didn't just go out and sue them and
I mean I worked with my therapist for
for months on this and and uh decided to
to finally pursue it because I thought
it'll kill me if I don't yeah I was I
was losing my mind Francis I know you
want to jump in and I just want to
finish this one thing real quick and
then have at it I actually have to go
right up we'll just cut it there no but
the reason I the thing I wanted to say
before Francis you take over is this
when I saw the story that this had
happened with you it kind of made me
laugh you know why because you're racist
exactly
I hate white people uh in the UK that's
no longer racist mate yeah yeah that's
Progressive yeah but in the UK this is
going on all the time yeah I had I
remember an incident where I I had
someone was not racist to me in the
street right and that day I got home
when I got in what was the race was it
white or no no it was dark because
you're right yeah I can I can go either
way this is my point right same day I
get home that evening I get an email
from a promoter saying I'm sorry we're
gonna have to change your dates because
there's too many white people on the
bill so I've just been you see what I'm
saying right and Francis will tell you
as well this is like it would never
occur to anyone on the UK comedy scene
to sue a manager or an agent who'd said
that yeah because this is just taken for
granted now it's normal it's normal it's
beyond normal it's so normal that
they're comfortable saying it even with
the little laugh you know I believe he
had a little giggle you know you know
the pendulum will swing back and I'm
going the pendulum is broken out of the
[ __ ] clock and it's just like
slamming everyone in the head I don't
want to hear the pendulum analogy you
know
so we can start with uh
the pandemic era Aid policies that have
been distributed on Race so there's the
American Rescue plan which was a two
trillion dollar bailout at the height of
the pandemic in 2021 to help Americans
that were struggling to help businesses
yeah part of that was 28 billion dollars
for restaurants that were going out of
business every day
and the program was done in such a way
that
anyone not white was put to the front of
the line automatically in so-called
priority groups if you're white
it took a lot more work to get into that
category
um
there was four billion dollars of aid
for Farmers with debt
only if you are non-white zero of that
money was available to you if you were a
white farmer with debt and there was
Zero money in the bill available to you
in general right so it was just a pot of
money only for non-white farmers
um
and again if you are
if you're a white restaurant owner or a
white struggling farmer that loses
their Farm in the context of a recession
where people are losing their businesses
every day and your business is your life
absolutely you are never going to
forgive that you were not treated on the
basis of need
but you were treated on the basis of
race just like black people in America
have not forgotten redlining Jim Crow
um you know convict Leasing
all of these policies that affected
black Americans
have not been forgotten and in many
cases have not been forgiven and we
should not expect that these kind of
things are going to be forgotten or
forgiven
and uh certainly not going to be excused
on the basis of paying for other
people's sins
fine completely baffling when you were
expect when you were talking about this
and when you're talking about it now
I just think the people who come up with
these ideas do they not realize this
really pisses people off quite rightly
and there will be a backlash yeah they
it's interesting I think
I think many people are able to
um ignore
the ignore the backlash in two ways so
in in one way they will just actually
not look at it right like a lot of
a lot of I think top Democrat Party
operatives would not actually like these
policies if they look them in the face
it's just they kind of sweep it under
the rug they don't report about it they
don't watch the Tucker Carlson segment
about it because why would they watch
that and they soft pedal it if you bring
it up they say oh it wasn't really that
it was something softer they used
language the orwellian euphemisms of
priority group and historically
disadvantaged group
um which you know all of which is
intended to soften the truth which is
that you gave people money limited money
because of the race that they happen to
be born into and you denied it to others
on the basis of race period
and so there's that but then there's
also
um the way this will be reported on is
the groups that
are part of the backlash well they are
maga-backed groups right so there's a
magabact lawsuit against the farmer bill
right when you read this in the New York
Times They will make sure to front load
for you and therefore prime prime you as
a reader so like I like I don't like
manga I don't like Trump I voted against
him twice so when I read that it's a
Maga backed lawsuit that's priming me to
say oh well we their anger doesn't count
well a bunch of racists being racist
they're a bunch of races being racist
exactly whereas if you were to meet one
of these people a white restaurant owner
struggling
um who may have had no you know you may
assume this person had quote-unquote
white privilege or whatever but you know
nothing about this person's background
like he might he might have struggled
just as much or more than a black
restaurant any given black restaurant
owner
um and
and you meet him and you look in his
eyes and you go to his restaurant and
and you see that this person was
reported on
as basically a quote angry white guy
and in a way that was intended to to let
you dismiss his anger as invalid I mean
you know and by the way what was the
Civil Rights Movement but a long overdue
backlash to Jim Crow laws that's what it
was so the the language of backlash I
think is it's intended to make you feel
that this is that people are reacting
and that they're coming from a place of
anger that's invalid
and I I think it should that anger
should be seen as
a
a
like a perfectly predictable consequence
of people being discriminated against
and the Discrimination should stop right
well this is what I was going to ask you
about because
um I I talk about it in my book uh about
one experience that I had in the UK when
I was invited to participate in a in a
TV discussion of these similar issues
um and afterwards one of the pre was a
panel of several people and afterwards
one of the presenters during the ad
break uh looked at me and they went I'm
so glad there weren't any white British
people here to be involved in this
conversation
and I was completely stunned by this
and it was only when I got home later I
was like why would they say that like
they know I don't agree with this
imagine I recorded that and I put that
out or whatever right
um
and then it was only when I got home
later that I realized
this is normal to these people
it's this way of thinking is normal now
it's a homeless situation in this in
this state is out of control the last
time I was here was 2007 and what I've
seen just driving about in the short
time that I've been here I found
genuinely shocking well there's so
there's another thing which is sort of
the
beginning of the end of a civilization
which is California has in very intense
rules for people who pay taxes and play
by the rules I mean insane
amount of Regulation red tape
but conversely if you do not want to pay
taxes or you can then construct yourself
a shelter on the side of the freeway and
you will be left alone so basically it's
this
we have some of the most stringent
building codes and they're up your ass
every step of the way so if you want to
you own a home and you want to build a
gazebo in your backyard that's a
two-year permit situation there but
if you'd like to not pay taxes or
property taxes and just build a plywood
home in the park you will be left alone
and that's why we have over regulated
for those who are playing by the rules
and almost zero regulation for anyone
who wants to just slam drugs and live in
the street and why is that what's the
philosophy behind that from from the
powers that be
I there's a there's a kind of a
weird system which is like you have
money you can afford a home you know
that that homeless person is sort of
noble and needs our help and we're gonna
punch Up We're not gonna punch down and
leave alone I I chronicled this in a a
book I wrote a few years ago which is I
started noticing
there's a street it's called Forest Lawn
Drive and it goes by the cemetery and
it's three miles from here and so
there's a big Cemetery there and so on
one side of the street you have a lot of
poor Latino people who go down to the
Flower Mart that's next please
[Laughter]
and they buy it's the most obnoxious so
they buy flowers and then they sell them
cheaply to people that are going to
visit Nana who've died four years ago
and and so on one side of the street you
have and it's a mess like the boxes and
the trash and everything on one side of
the street and they're just running a
bootleg flower shop from the street
they're just Street vendors you know and
street street vendors everywhere here as
you guys probably know okay on the other
side of the street there's a cop
and the cops on a motorcycle and he's
backed up the driveway to the Jewish
cemetery and he's got his radar gun out
he's given tickets
to taxpayers and soccer moms that are
going five miles an hour too fast Town
Forest line drive the other side of the
street is illegal activity going on and
first off they're not paying taxes
nothing's permitted they don't have a
business license they're undercutting
the flower store up the street who has
to pay insurance and and all the
expenses that occurred with running a
business in Los Angeles those people
operate with impunity and our government
is handing out tickets to the soccer mom
who's driving her kid to school I
noticed that about 10 years ago and I
was like something's broken here you
either have to bust both people or you
got to let the soccer mom go too
and so we start that's the path that's a
progressive path I don't know what I
don't know what's considered
compassionate about letting people just
sort of die in the streets or sell their
goods in the streets or all cash under
the town it's some compassion we also
have a racial thing too because those
are Hispanic people on that side of the
street and if you come down on them then
that's going to be like a bad optic
we're we're a mess we don't know what I
I
I went out on a boat with a guy who ran
the Staple Center which is now I don't
know the crypto Center or whatever it is
and I said to him I I walked out of a
Lakers game a couple years ago with my
son who's besieged with people with
makeshift hot dog carts and propane
tanks just selling street food but I
said it was all on your property it's
all on the Staples Center it wasn't it
was right by the right this the door and
why did you walk out of the venues I
could bang into a guy that
he pulled out his phone and he showed me
a picture of one of those carts with a
giant cockroach cooking on it and he
said he said we hate it we hate it
what can you do I said well what can you
do you're you're inside charging 14
bucks for a hot dog these guys are
charging two bucks for a hot dog there's
no permit there's no license they're
dealing with food there's no Health
ordinance or something they're on your
property they're just selling he said oh
yeah they they load them up in Vans and
they bring them out you know and they're
all cooking out front there
I said go to the city council you guys
are one of the biggest taxpayers in the
you you took downtown and resurrected it
by building the Staples Center you got
to be one of the biggest taxpayers
Employers in the city go down to the
commission the city council tell them to
clean this [ __ ] up we don't want this
stuff at it he goes I don't want to get
into trouble
what that's why there's exact words
amazing I don't get it I don't I don't
need that kind of trouble what does that
mean it just means if he he as the
taxpayer who runs the Staples Center if
he goes to the city council and says I
want you to get these people off of my
whatever they'll go after him
that's I mean we did the same with covet
it's like that's that's just where we're
at that's why people are leaving have
you and this is what I was going to ask
you because when we were in Austin we we
did Joe Rogan's show and one of the
things he's trying to do is get a bunch
of people down there sort of like a
building you've seen have you ever
thought of moving yes
but you haven't
no
and that's why I'm a good interview
we reference it at the start of the
interview one of my our favorite
routines of yours is the white privilege
routine it's brilliant it's brilliant
and and I think the reason it hits is
look it's wonderfully funny let's just
say that first of all but I think the
reason it hits
because you're telling the truth
yeah so I had to step as guide us
through how did you how did you make
that happen how did you well they didn't
like you know sometimes like poor poor
white people get left out of like the
the poverty conversation I feel like
sometimes Maybe
it's hard to like
it's kind of [ __ ] sometimes you're like
if you're white right and I'm polish a
Nicaraguan right and but if you are
white or looked at as a white you know
Whitey honky wiggers whatever they call
them you know
um
I don't know what they call them in
what do you guys call them yeah a couple
[ __ ] you know little chabs right at
AR
um if you are chavs or just regular
white people poor white people then yeah
I felt like a lot of times
um when people think of like poor they
think of just
uh ethnicities first a lot of times you
know and so and you always feel bad
anyway because white people you're just
supposed to have money right so
automatically out of the gate you're
like how the [ __ ] do we not have
a little bit more money than this right
right if you've had a couple generations
and you've shown up in the you know in
the correct uniform yeah how would you
not have a bit more of a you know
Treasure Chest you know but but you know
that's what you get born into and so
that's that and uh and yeah it kind of
feels like you don't really get a voice
sometimes you know
um and then
yeah so I think that was part of my
thing it was like
I'm I ride the same bus as the poor
black kids the poor we only had black
and white in our town
but like you know when people think of
um
when people think of yeah helping like
sometimes they they would miss us you
know it would feel like sometimes and
now also
maybe that's just a feeling and maybe
that's not even the reality but it was
my perception sometimes you know I
wasn't angry at black people for it I
just was like well this is my truth you
know right and sometimes it feels like
uh
they don't know where to put that truth
in like a mainstream
space right it doesn't fit that
if you're not if you're poor and white
and not a racist person or you know
somebody who's mating with their
you know siblings or whatever then
you um
they don't it's almost like yeah work
yeah like you don't exist but you do and
there's a lot of you you know
hey Francis do you like locals I live in
London Mike so obviously not the only
pleasure I get from the locals is when
we share an intimate moment as we watch
a Japanese tourists get trapped in a
tube door that is good but I wasn't
talking about their locals I was talking
about our community on locals you mean
the one where you get phenomenal behind
the scenes content when you thank you
when you get to wasp incredible guests
like Jordan Peterson Brett Weinstein
Bill Burr Sam Harris Adam Carolla
Heather Hein and others your questions
not just that you can get supporter only
benefits like trigonometry mugs monthly
calls with our other top supporters and
even a regular meal with me and Francis
you also get phenomenal
behind-the-scenes footage of our trip to
America where we met a whole host of
incredible guests and gave ourselves
terminal indigestion we're also starting
to do monthly giveaways for locals only
the first one will be signed copies of
Andrew door's new book plus you get
access to an incredible community of
like-minded people who share memes have
fun conversations and most importantly
you get to make new friends you can
support us with as little as seven
dollars or about five pounds a month or
give us more for the higher tier
benefits go to
trigonometry.locals.com go to
trigonometry.locals.com and support the
show
do you really want to live in a country
where you have a digital Public Square
which in my opinion Twitter is we can
disagree about that if you want but
that's my opinion it's a digital Public
Square and you have a company that has
clearly one-sided enforcement I I hear
what you're saying about delegitimizing
the electoral process that Trump did
right and I was concerned about that I
think you can't question the system in
that way
but when you see that he gets banned and
then a story about Hunter Biden gets
banned that under the guise of it being
Russian disinformation we later learn it
wasn't Russian disinformation that a lot
of people seems like you know I said
when we were talking to Joe Rogan it's
putting your hand on the scales yeah in
favor of one side in the digital Public
Square you add that to the Banning of
trump and lots of other people being
banned from one side predominantly right
is that is that the world you want to
live in where one team gets to just ban
people it disagrees with off the
platform it gets to pretend that things
that are true and not true it gets to
shut down the sharing of information
with people who want to make their own
Democratic choice
well it's a it's a hard question and
there are pieces of the question that
are individually hard it's like the
hunter Biden laptop story is something
that I still
don't have a
a full opinion about I actually don't
know what we should have done about that
I mean so I see the reason I see both
sides of of it I can argue either side
of it the the so let's leave that piece
aside
the bias on the platform so so either
Twitter is a company that can do what it
wants right it can have its own terms of
service it can change its policies it
can you can change you know it can
decide to you know it can have a point
of view or not right or
we have to seize it as some kind of
you know crucial piece of public
infrastructure that has to to you don't
think that it is a commercial piece of
public infrastructure I think I think
people who are addicted to Twitter feel
it is
most you know and and I think it's you
know I don't think it should should be
um
and it's it's odd to say that it's just
so it's first of all it's just I mean
Facebook is much much bigger right it's
just that we have a lot of smart people
journalists uh Brands uh political
people focus concentrated on Twitter so
Twitter moves the the conversation more
than Facebook does but it's it's it's a
scale of it is much smaller
um
I don't know I just feel like
people can start their own companies
which they have right they can start
competitors at Twitter there are many
people who you know Twitter is not it's
it's still a failing business right it's
like it's not
it doesn't work really I mean Facebook
is is a much better business
um
there's nothing stopping Facebook from
becoming stickier for intellectuals and
journalists and that's a attracting more
of the conversation over there
um
I don't know it's just it's an extreme
move to say
you you can't
you can't be biased right like who's
who's going to say that but behind
behind the scene of that is a law in the
end
and they're and therefore it's a gun
therefore it's it's jail time for the
person who wants to keep breaking the
law right so like just imagine imagine
it's Twitter the Twitter board is like
what you everyone gets what they want
you know everyone who's who's of this
opinion gets what they want you just
we're gonna we're gonna come in and and
and enforce something like
um
a zero bias state in Twitter and so far
as that's possible
and if the if the employees and the
board just say you know sorry we we have
a point of view we want we want to have
we we don't like these people and we
like these people
um
what's so now you just break up the
company you just say you know I mean I I
thought what I thought it should have
happened with Twitter is I thought
Jack Dorsey should have deleted it I
mean I literally thought he should would
have got the Nobel Peace Prize
at the same point deleted it right
um
but
uh yeah I don't so in any case should
there should they be forced to be
impartial I'm very skeptical of that
should they be cajoled by unhappy people
like yourselves or like you know the uh
um
the Trump fans to um
I mean I think so yeah yes I think
if they were going to be the first thing
to admit is it may be impossible to do
this impeccably right it's like it's
like the until we have you know perfect
artificial intelligence it's just going
to be impossible to be
truly consistent with your terms of
service because
you're always going to be able to find
the example of the thing that was not
appropriately moderated yes but if we
all know that if that laptop was Donald
Trump's Junior oh yeah this would be
treated that's that's all I'm asking oh
yeah also but that's so let's take that
piece
um
I think it was totally appropriate to
view Trump
e in a
to be existing in a in a domain that was
orthogonal to partisan politics I my
criticism of trump is totally
nonpartisan right there is absent
there's literally nothing I say about
Trump that I could say about any other
Republican right and I think Liz Cheney
is a total hero right so so and I don't
agree with her politics at all right
like Liz Cheney is a religious Maniac by
my lights right and in in that sense
kind of a terrifying political figure
like like that like the the old me who
you know was just worried about the
Christian theocracy in the United States
um would have just
revolted at everything she would attempt
to implement as a politician but
at this moment she's you know she has no
bigger fan than me
because of how she's dealing with the
Trump phenomenon the Trump phenomenon is
not a matter of political partisanship
he is a he's just a Sweden heiress uh
phenomenon and it's
again it's it's analogous to have an
elected Alex Jones president United
States it's it's a it's a
it's not a matter of his part like I
probably agree with half of his policies
or more than half of his policies is not
a matter of policy it's a matter of
having someone who's totally unfit to
have power be given more power than any
person in a generation and and he's
unfit for
in every possible way it's like it's not
it's not that he's just got a few screws
loose like every screw is loose every
screw that you would want totally crank
down is lose or non-existent in him
um and so yeah so it's that's my
argument it's like so my argument is
that it was appropriate for Twitter
and the heads of big Tech and journal
and the heads of journalistic
organizations
to feel that they were in the presence
of something like a a once in a lifetime
moral emergency right where this is not
the same thing as not liking George Bush
you know or not liking John McCain or
not liking Mitt Romney for their
politics this was here's a guy who
is capable of anything right he's not
he's not ideological but he's again he's
a black hole of selfishness right he's
he's just so there's no telling what
he's going to do
um
and we cannot afford to have four more
years with this guy right and and so
um
so what what should
well-intentioned people do who have a
lot of power in these various ways you
know you're running the New York Times
you're running CNN you're running
Twitter
what should they've conspire to do those
conditions well admit that Trump is
their fault
absolutely that that's what no that
that's the perverse thing it's totally
their fault he I mean CNN CNN gave us
Trump right without no before CNN gave
us Trump Mark Burnett gave us Trump I
mean if there's one person who could
have
not done what he did and and could have
closed the door of this whole phenomenon
it was Mark Burnett
um
but
yeah no by giving him the attention you
know but he was he was great ratings you
know for a year for the whole run-up to
to the 2016 election
oh yeah no there no one has Clean Hands
here but it at the 11th Hour when it's
when
who knows how this election is going to
go who know who knows what the capacity
for
you know disinformation at the last
minute to to tip the balance is
then what do you do with the hunter
Biden laptop story
when we already know we we know how this
played out in 2016 with the Hillary
Clinton email you know press conference
where Comey in in an abundance of
scrupulosity felt like he had to come
before the cameras I think 10 days out
from the election and say you know we've
we're going to open up this this
investigation again because we've got
Anthony Weiner's laptop
we could see I mean again her failure to
become president was over determined she
was an appallingly bad candidate
um but in terms of just tracking the
poll numbers you could like that was
that was the killing blow to her
candidacy right that that final moment
and this was a this was a highly
analogous situation this was we're going
to open up this laptop from hell
and the News cycle for who knows how
long is going to be just just
[Music]
conceivably just a nuclear bomb of an
October October surprise and we're going
to get four more years of trump if we
actually give this a fair hearing but
Sam you can't do that Sam surely you've
got to realize that you've got to be
fair and number the thing that I want to
do we're all equal before the law yeah
and the other this isn't the look but I
know this is not the law but if this is
if you accept my my supposition that
this is the Public Square then it is the
law it is if it is the Public Square
then it is law now you're arguing it's
not the Public Square which is fair
enough yeah right that's fine but why
don't we move on because I think we've
done enough yeah sure yeah
no but I'll just say there's finally I I
do again
it's like a coin toss for me the hunter
Biden laptop thing because I I do
understand how
corrosive it is
for an institution like the the New York
Times to show obvious bias and
inconsistency and dishonesty in how they
it's like they couldn't even frame it
honestly it's not like
it's not like it's like the way I would
frame it is uh
listen I don't care what's in Hunter
Biden's I mean a hunter Biden at that
point Hunter Biden literally could have
had the corpses of children in his
basement I would not have cared right
it's like there's nothing first of all
it's Hunter Biden right it's not it's
like it's not Joe Biden but even if Joe
like even whatever scope of Joe Biden's
corruption is like if you if we could
just go down that rabbit hole endlessly
and and understand that he's getting
kickbacks from Hunter and Biden's deals
in Ukraine or whatever else right or
China
it is
infinitesimal
compared to the corruption we know Trump
is involved in it's like it's like it's
like a firefly to the sun right I mean
like there's just it doesn't even it
doesn't even stack up against Trump
University right Trump University as a
story is worse than anything that could
be in in Hunter Biden's laptop in my
view right now that's not that doesn't
answer the people who say it's still
completely unfair
to not have looked at the laptop in a
timely way and to have shut down the you
know the New York post's twitter account
like that that's a just a conspiracy
that's a left-wing conspiracy to deny
the presidency to Donald Trump
absolutely it was absolutely right but I
think it was warranted right and I'm and
again it's a coin toss as to whether or
not Simon I'm sorry that particular
piece I'm really sorry I was the one
that said we should move on but you've
just said something I really struggled
with that which is
the kids in the basement you no no [ __ ]
the kids in the basement I'm interested
in democracy you're saying you are
content with the left-wing conspiracy to
prevent somebody being democratically
re-elected as president well no I'm
content well so but the thing is it's
just not left wing right so Liz Cheney
is not left wing right Liz Cheney
to prevent somebody from being
Democratic no but there's nothing
conspiracy it's not it was a conspiracy
out in the open it does but it doesn't
matter if it doesn't matter what parts
conspiracy what parts out in the open I
mean I think it's like if people get
together and talk and talk about what
should we do about this phenomenon you
know if it's like if there was an
asteroid hurtling toward Earth
and and we got in a room together with
all of our friends and had a
conversation about what we could do to
deflect its course right is that a
conspiracy you know like some of that
conversation would be in public some of
it would be in private
we have a massive problem we have an
existential threat right politically
speaking I consider Trump an existential
threat to our democracy right now it's
not he's not going to destroy the world
very likely it destroyed democracy in
the process of protecting democracy but
that doesn't destroy it no our
I'm not what I'm not suggesting at no
point was I suggesting we should stuff
ballots or or actually break the
Machinery of democracy but
the all political opinion is already
being just completely inundated with
misinformation bias takes half truths
and outright lies right like and or just
the amplification of bad or misleading
information based on you know the
algorithm right
um
so that's it's like it's already
just an abattoir
of opinion right and now the question is
you know what can you do with your own
biases and your own the the to to get
the outcome you think is actually better
not just for yourself personally but for
the world right so like I have like it
is I'm completely unconflicted in
in the claim
that a TR that a a first Trump term was
bad and a second Trump term would be bad
and it literally doesn't matter what was
what what else was on the the menu like
literally pick up pick a random American
better than Trump in the in the Oval
Office like the the likelihood that
you're going to get someone who's worse
than Trump
give given what I consider that is bad
about Trump is
I mean it's
on the order of one in a million right
like you're just not you're not gonna
get you're not gonna get worse than
Trump if you pick at random and you know
Hillary Clinton for all of her flaws was
not worse than Trump Joe Biden Joe Biden
we could have known Joe Biden was going
to just be comatose in office not worse
than Trump right
um Kamala hair is not worth like like
it's all and and again it's not just a
marginal call it's just these are people
who are
normal politicians who are so much more
constrained by predictable Machinery
right there's there's like there's
there's such less
of an opportunity there to
destroy institutions that we have to
rely on right with any of those people
in charge including a random person in
charge a random person who's going to be
terrified at the responsibility of the
office and default to expert opinion you
know across the board
um
no Trump is again a trump is an Alex
Jones level figure for me and okay and
so you know it's it's like a smaller
problem is to just for some billionaire
to buy the New York Times and give it to
Alex Jones to run right that would be an
enormous catastrophic loss and mistake
but that's a smaller problem than
getting Trump reelected what should we
know what should people understand about
this regime that we've been doing
business with what are some of the
things that have been happening that a
lot of a lot of outlets in the west are
just not covering well okay so the the
obvious one is the Oregon harvesting uh
you know I I call it murder for organs
industry
um uh more commonly it's called the
forced organ harvesting
reality in China it's the only place in
the world where it's state-sanctioned uh
if not State directed you know there's
some debate about that among the people
that are studying this
um but to make a long story short well
actually why don't I'll tell a bit of
story okay I believe it was in 2006 or
2005 or 2006.
um and is an Israeli transplant doctor
named Jacob Levy
um had a patient and Israel has the
policy where if you need to get a trans
life-saving transplant you can go out of
country the state pays for them okay
um he he his patient tells him I'm going
to China I'm going to get this
transplant heart transplant I'm gonna
get it in two weeks and Jakob is as a
transplant sir by the way head of the
Israeli transplant Association also he's
shocked and stunned and he understands
immediately that there's no ethical way
that this could happen because see a
heart transplant is something that you
can't actually schedule because you
would have to know when someone's going
to be dead and the only way you can
really know when someone's going to be
dead to give that heart is to make them
so
okay so you know he's kind of stunned by
this the guy goes comes back and
basically he's got the transplant later
there's complications that's a different
story but Jacob takes the time and in a
couple of years the Israeli Parliament
has adopted a law that says if you go to
China to get a transplant we will not
pay for it one of the few countries to
this day by the way that's adopted such
a law it's very very interesting but
this is at this point we already knew
that something terrible is happening to
Canadian Human Rights uh two Canadian
lawyers uh uh David Kilgore they call
them the two Davids David Culver David
made us they actually looked at the body
of evidence that was available at the
time in 2006 they found yes definitely
there's an industry in China the murder
for organs industry and the most likely
people that are being used for it are
the falun gong why the falun gong why
because there there's millions of them
in the labor camps they're a group
that's targeted for eradication so it's
easy when you easier for people to do
things like this right order for organs
and so forth so and I remember I
interviewed David Kilgore back in 2006
about this he had he had spoken with a
guy who had gone to China and got a
kidney transplant they had fitted him
with eight he had a rare antibody
condition they had fitted him with eight
separate kidneys on two separate trips
the eighth one was the one that took
because the basically the antibody
situation wasn't an issue for that one
so you can just imagine how many people
likely lost their lives along the way to
get to that one transplant
um more recently okay and this is this
is I think what you could call the the
the best Smoking Gun evidence that
exists but yeah I'll go back to Jakob
Levy him and a journalist uh uh Matthew
Robertson they put to they basically
looked at all these Chinese officially
published Chinese studies in medical
journals and they found through looking
at protocols very carefully 71 instances
in the published literature where people
had been killed by heart extraction
okay the the cause of death was
certainly their heart removal of a heart
and they've just they published this in
the American Journal of transplantation
recently so you know it's been this
Quest so to speak since that time to try
to convince people that this is really
something that's actually happening for
starters and you know it's really only I
think this year that I I hear kind of
broad acceptance and there's been a lot
of hurdles give everybody a sense of the
scale of what's Happening how many
people do you think are likely to have
gone through this I just had a
conversation with Ethan Gutman maybe a
couple of weeks ago Ethan was I think
the
Premiere field researcher on this issue
he's lived in falun gong communities and
in uyghur communities this shifted later
by the way into the uighur communities
as another extremely vulnerable
vulnerable group to be used for this
practice but the the estimate a credible
estimate since about 2002 is 60 to 100
000 transplants a year
and then if you and then I said well
that that would be could be more than a
million people and Ethan said no no yeah
that's an overestimate because the
because of ECMO technology so ECMO is a
type of machine that allows you to
replace the heart and lungs it's often
used when people need very complicated
surgeries and they you know maybe around
those organs or something like this so
around 2007 2008 ECMO technology started
being used so you could conceivably
because this is important to know you
can only really transplant from a body
that's brain dead and body alive you
can't transplant from cadavers so it's
it it there's limited time frame right
this gives you apparently 24 according
to Ethan another 24 hours so you could
do multiple transplants that match
tissue and and blood and all this all
this so ultimately his estimate and I
think and he's very conservative in his
estimates is about half a million people
but the thing that struck me was I was
looking at the black are you familiar
with the black book of Communism right
uh Chronicles the the deaths of various
communist regimes this you know is
a significant just this organ harvesting
machine let's take that million of 500
that is that number of 500 000 people
500 000 people killed four organs in
China is a significant number in the
list of the black book primary alone
never mind the Great Leap Forward never
mind the cultural Evolution never mind
you know what happened in the Soviet
Union so yeah it's been it's been pretty
nuts uh so I left I was working at a a
place called fair and I left that job
because I wanted to go full time on my
sub stack to tackle the gender sex
denials and stuff because to me that's
just it's like the eye of the storm it's
like the craziest stuff that's where I
want to focus on my attention
um but then that that's kind of a scary
thing because then I'm completely
reliant on payment processors I'm sub
stack uses stripe they're pretty good
um they've kind of routinely come out
Pro free speech and things like that
um but I was also using PayPal to to
solicit donations of people if they
didn't want to just subscribe to my sub
stack but they wanted to give me
donations directly monthly one-time
donations or whatever they could do so
through PayPal so I had received an
email from PayPal just out of the blue
just saying you can no longer use PayPal
I think that was the the subject line
and I thought this was had to be
completely of the maybe my credit card
is not working or if I need to update
something and then going through you
know trying to to turn it back on well
they're every everywhere I went led to
like a dead end so I called like the the
help desk just to Something's clearly a
miss here and they said that you know
they would put me in touch with somebody
who'd be able to tell me what's going on
expect an email well I never got an
email they sent me a message through the
PayPal system saying that if I want to
find out why my account was turned off
that I would need to submit have an
attorney submit a subpoena a legal
subpoena to find out so yeah that's
that's all I know they didn't say any
reason why my account was shut down in
the first place
so we can only imagine they've done the
same thing to Ian miles Chung they
recently also shut down Mom's for
Liberty account their PayPal account so
this is sort of a pattern that they have
of people that they disagree with
politically on this
um and it puts me in a precarious
position because I'm completely reliant
on these systems now I don't work for a
company I work for myself and so I need
to have a way where people can pay me
you know directly or through through
some sort of system so it's really kind
of a scary thing where does some some
intern at PayPal or maybe it's at stripe
now I hope I hope they're as robust as
I'm hoping they are
um but you know just a single click and
they can just turn off my entire income
and have you been able to appeal or
challenge in any way are you considering
following the legal route I'm
considering going and actually just
making them give me the reason so doing
the The subpoena route so that's sort of
in the works but we're not quite right
there yet and then also so it wasn't
just PayPal but I also had an Etsy store
you know it wasn't like a big part of my
income but every once in a while oh yeah
so Etsy is like this online
store that people can set up their
little shops it was originally known for
people selling like homemade Goods like
they'd knitting or something or they'd
make earrings with rocks or something
like that yeah
exactly and then it sort of expanded
more and now you can just host you can
sell anything you want to Shirts Mugs a
lot of people use it for that just
because it's got like low fees for
people who are hosting their stuff
um and then they sent me an email saying
that I could no longer use Etsy and
permanently banned from Etsy now they
did give me a reason they said that my
merchandise was I think the wording was
supporting and glorifying hatred against
protected groups but if you actually saw
the merchandise that I had on there it
was I literally only sold three things I
had so my my sub stack is called
reality's Last Stand so I had some mugs
that just had the words of reality's
Last Stand and they had a male and a
female symbol I had another logo that
said defender of reality and it had male
and female symbol boo I guess these are
hate symbols now yeah
um and then I had my political cartoon
the poster I gave you of the one Elon
Musk tweeted out that just showed you
know how my perception sort of the left
had gone really left and the center had
moved past me and now I'm perceived as
being on the right so that's there's
nothing hateful there
um but apparently this was was
considered glorifying violence against
minorities I did try to appeal and they
said nope we stand by our decision
meanwhile they do sell things that say
like you know kill turfs they have
things that are like Turf Stoppers and a
Turf is someone who like criticizes
gender ideology it stands for Trans
exclusionary radical feminist and they
have things that are clear really
glorifying violence against those types
of people but I can't sell just like a
mug that has the name of mine my sub
stack on it apparently
a hundred years ago
how many people
were confused about
their gender like how many how many men
were going around who really thought
that they were women I'm sure there were
some like very very small numbers and
they were mental ill it's a mental
illness and if we were still a sane
Society we would treat that with therapy
counselings what you do for mentally ill
people you treat their minds to the best
of your ability
um
this astronomical rise though in
transgender identification that's
obviously not
uh just mental illness it's not
something people are born with there's
something happening in the culture
clearly
because yeah God and because in the film
like the first half an hour was really
funny I was sitting there with the lads
and we were you know we were laughing
we're going like oh this is not bull
saying this I wasn't laughing I saw the
trouble coming yeah but I was laughing
because I think you you exposed these
elements of it and it was comically
humorous but then what was terrifying is
when we saw the medical professionals
the doctors affirming this did you
expect that because I certainly didn't
yeah I think well that's one thing I was
a little bit worried about actually with
the film before it came out is that we
knew we were gonna have this tonal shift
and I don't know is it too abrupt is
it's kind of weird and it is abrupt and
weird but at the same time I think it's
also necessary that like on the surface
level this is absurd and so we laugh
at absurdity which is an appropriate
response
um but then you go a little bit under
the surface you see there's some really
Sinister stuff going on and that's when
you get into the the doctors who are
um encouraging you know who are sort of
spreading this plague and doing it in a
really intentional way and and doctors I
think certainly know better and you know
we talked to one a pediatrician in the
film uh four CA who prescribes these
drugs chemical castration drugs to
children
and um
what what was so revolting about that
aside from just you know the obvious
is that when I talked to her like she
had no
defense of the practice at all she was
not able to even begin to defend this
and yet she's doing it and so that makes
you think well
if she can't defend it then she must
know that this is wrong that's just my
you know that that that's my
interpretation
is that a lot of these people know what
they're doing is wrong and yet they do
it anyway
why would they do it anyway well one big
thing is money there's there's a huge
financial incentive we'll get into that
a little bit in the film but
you have to keep in mind there's
billions of dollars not for one
individual but like for these industries
there's billions of dollars at stake
um
and you think about you know you got a
six-year-old kid who says that your
six-year-old boy says he's confused
about his gender
and if you were to just say to the
six-year-old boy Oh no you're a boy
and help him to accept himself for who
he is then that's great that's the right
thing to do but there's no money in that
right
of if on the other hand you encourage
him
to go delve even deeper into that
confusion then that boy is worth
thousands if not millions of dollars
to Big Pharma therapists doctors down
the line so I think there's a real
Financial incentive and you know we've
interviewed a ton of people about this
trans people who don't agree with some
elements of this ideology uh other
people gender critical feminists Etc
and yet I was still shocked by the
second half of the movie were you
shocked by what you found in
particularly with doctors and and
professors I was uh
yeah that's the thing even when you
encounter something that you already
knew about intellectually it's still
shocking just to encounter it exactly to
I knew that so-called sex change or what
they call gender affirmation surgeries
now which is if a euphemism if I ever
heard one but uh I knew that that was
happening and yet to sit across from
someone who does this and hear the
explain it it's still shocking just to
encounter it and I was also shy there
were some things I learned like I before
getting into the film making the film
and researching it before we filmed it I
I I did not realize
how young the kids are when they start
them on
the actual medical transition part of it
how young are they man
well I mean as young as uh as young as
10 11 years olds when they start them on
the on the hormones and you get into
puberty blockers the surgery especially
i i a year and a half ago
I didn't realize that they were actually
that they really were mutilating kids I
thought that you know this is something
that starts at the age of 18 but no I
mean they chop the breasts off of uh
13 and 14 year old girls even younger
sometimes I didn't I didn't realize that
and it's um I think a lot of people
don't don't realize that that's
happening
and uh hopefully now they do
does it worry you Bill that people are
more divided than ever that we've got
this kind of Left Right divide and the
left looks at the right and the right
looks at the left and no one seems to
really trust each other anymore
uh no I just don't think any of that's
real it's not real it's just saying the
people from England and around you guys
always ask these questions like what's
it like everybody yelling at each other
and walking around with a machine gun
and it's just like it's like you know
what I mean I'm trying to think of The
Stereotype of where you guys come from
it's just it's just not this it's it's
it's kind of you you are what they show
and what what everybody shows now is
heightened emotions because there's so
many places to look at things like crazy
gets people to stop and watch but like
actual you know people just chilling out
no one wants to see that they want to
see like fighting and that type of thing
so
um I know what you're saying but we've
been talking to people hey you've been
here for a week you got it down man
please by all means tell me about my
country
yeah
I'm just asking the question bill yeah
that's cool I answered it you think
you're still going back yeah
I know you guys are going to go back to
England oh they're [ __ ] fat
everybody's got a gun in the visor of
their car I know what you guys are going
to do you know actually Americans are
not that fat it's the fat Americans who
are extra fat most Americans are the
same as the British well our food supply
is poison yeah it was taken over by one
group of people and they own the rights
to the seeds and all of that type of
stuff and they forced out all of these
Farmers if their seeds blew under their
property they could sue them for using
their seeds and the media just ignored
all of that because they get paid by
them that's sort of what is going on
globally is everybody's is just choosing
money the bag is [ __ ] kids say
nowadays
um that's what the problem is nobody is
uh you know everybody's screaming and
yelling about [ __ ] that doesn't matter
like stand-up comedians they'll yell
about that but they won't talk about
literally people uh point reasoning
their own countrymen I mean they should
be [ __ ] put to death for what they
did
there you go there's a hot take I mean I
know if I did it if I did it if I
[ __ ] went to one donut shop and put
something in a [ __ ] donut
that hurts somebody or caused them to
have some sort of medical episode that
would be a I would not be sitting here
right now but they somehow you know you
know how it is Catholic Church can do
what they do
kind of move people around and uh
everything's all right as long as you
[ __ ] you know you're paying people
it's good so
that's what it is
you talk a lot about masculinity in your
current special why is it that you talk
about it so much now was it because I've
never talked about masculinity I talked
about myself oh okay right and then
you're rebranding it as masculine
masculinity I'm just glad you didn't say
toxic
but you know
I spoke about masculinity is because
it's a lot of a lot of things that men
connect with you know that feeling you
know of anger you know the the
relationship with the father not being
able to process that having kids being a
dad and going oh I don't want to pass
this stuff on to my kid right I'm sure
my dad thought that I think I mean my
kids will will think that there's always
stuff that you're gonna like
you know you're gonna make mistakes
um I just think the big thing is
apologizing to them and addressing in
the moment that you did it that you
messed up and that you're really sorry
and then I go back to it two or three
times
um
I did that messed up the other day with
my daughter and then uh
I was saying yeah I can't believe I did
that I really the third time I apologize
I I was like it makes me sad that I did
that and she was like I don't want you
to be sad I was just like all right it's
good now we're good now yeah it was
really cute I became a dad a few months
ago so I haven't got to that stage yet
how has that changed you the experience
of being becoming a father and being a
father
um oh God I actually the thing I learned
is like you know you think you know you
buy some
huge house and they have all the toys
and then you're gonna have like this
you're gonna raise a good empathetic
person it's not how it works it's like
you can give them everything in the
world the one the biggest thing that
they need is your time
so if you're busy like everybody in this
business is
um you have to say no to stuff and you
have to like you know like my big thing
was I went on you know everything has an
app now like my daughter's school has an
app so I just looked up when's your fall
break when's the Christmas break when's
February when's April and I just sent
that to everybody I'm not working these
weeks so
um
you know uh
yeah she said some like heartbreaking
[ __ ] to me like kids just kids really
get to like you know I shot a movie
earlier this year
and she's like Dad can you you know can
you hang out with me today and I was
like ah you know I go I gotta work today
she's like oh and I said no I go I'm I
got two more days left in this movie
and she goes uh
she goes I don't like when you do movies
I was like I don't like it I go I don't
like it either and then she goes I go
but I'm done in two days and she goes
good then you can play with me forever
and I was like
and you just walk out like I am the
worst parent but it's just like this is
how I [ __ ]
pay for our life so I have to go do this
[ __ ] so
um
like those things you have to let those
things land and sit in the pain of them
and be like all right I need to make
sure I do and then just like I'm gonna
have to go to work
so I just have to make sure I don't work
I gotta have that balance of
you know keeping the lights on and then
like like being there but like I am
there a lot though that is the great
thing about this job is like I kind of
work when I want to work
um it's just once every two weeks I go
away for three days you know on you know
some sort of gig or whatever but I don't
do anything longer than like three three
four days the last question we ask and
this is gonna sound funny given what
you've just said is what's the one thing
when when bad not bad
it's been a long day dude you ask him
the question yeah okay so Theo the last
question we always ask is what's the
thing
[Music]
is this mere this is a good mirror yeah
it is a good mirror did this chain be
out the whole time oh no it's good
all right what's the one thing we're not
talking about that we really should be
um
I think they
oh dude I remember one time I saw these
massive Birds right they call them in
Europe yeah it's beautiful strong
uh
I swear bro I went to this I went to
this place called Newcastle have you
heard of this yes yeah Newcastle and
this taxi drops me off and there was
these it was like a part like a
I don't know if it was look like a
bachelorette party or something and and
this foyer of like a big there was a big
room like a big window and they were in
there naked you know what do you call it
tits yes yes tits
and they were beating each other with
pillows in there bro and I sat out there
and watched smoked a cigarette out there
right out there and that's the one thing
no one's talking about huh and that's
the one thing I was talking about there
was seven of these women in there
I can see why you brought it up
it was serious man oh
sounds fantastic well Theo
it was serious bro see I can't even do
it justice because you can't even
believe that it could happen could you
how who would get seven women naked and
have them pillow fight in front of a big
huge pitcher window someone's thought
they wanted to be seen for you I don't
know man that's [ __ ] that's beautiful
bro
it was good [ __ ] man all right so where
you guys headed next man uh we're going
to see the comedy show that you're part
of oh [ __ ] man I forgot
hahaha
[Music]
[Music]